I mean, I'll only put out parts which are matching to the video.
I want to put out the whole thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. But it's also also for you,
yeah. Exactly so that I can
understand. Yeah, but you will read the
document also. Yeah.
So profile theory, we have a moment coefficient on profile,
which is the shape of the profile doesn't rely to rigidity
or whatsoever. It could be, it could be made of
steel would be the same because we are airplanes without tails,
OK, You see the pitch stability, we don't have tails, right?
You see airplanes, you have tails, right?
Right, right, right. Right.
OK. So our stability relies on the
profile profile shape. OK.
So this profile shape we could, we could it profile it has a
moment coefficient and the moment coefficient can vary from
something very stable where the lift resultant the force lifting
you is very in the front of the profile and when the moment
coefficient is more negative or smaller, it's more on the back.
The more you're, when you have a very stable profile, the more
you diminish the angle of attack, the more the lift force
move forward, Yeah. And the more you have stability
that you can understand if you think deeply about it.
And the other fact is to change the speed on the paraglider, We
we do like that we change the twin by applying speed system
and then the angle of attack of equilibrium changes and the
force can move forward or backward depending on the CM.
OK, when you have ACM that is low.
CM full form. Coefficient of moment OK.
When your CM is low, your force is more on the back and help to
create even more speed up aggressive more speed out of a
given speed range. So on the CCC, the holes make a
limitation on the speed system, which is everyone, every wing
should be within 14 centimetre of speed travel.
And so when you make a profile that is very stable in pitch,
you don't get a lot of speed out of this 14 centimetre.
I see. OK.
So when you go competing with this wing which will never
collapse on the bar because it's very stable, you won't be able
to compete properly because on final light you will be slower
than the guys. OK.
So this system of rules makes an optimum powerglider to win
competition to be very limit on stability, on pitch stability.
Otherwise you you're not competitive.
So this is a problematic situation because manufacturers
and pilots, they are pushed into compromising stability in order
to get more competitiveness spirit.
Yeah, out of the. 14 range basically.
Yeah, exactly. This is quite clear and a lot of
people have understood this. When we set up the rules, it was
it was not of use. I was on the team that set up
these rules many years ago and it was having some advantages
because it's super easy to check.
It's quite clear there is no cheating around.
It's, it's a good rule anyway. But the, the side effect is that
it doesn't let the, the safety because people are pushed to
compromise the stability, you understand, for, for more speed.
So there are different solutions to that.
But maybe we can talk about here the competition.
So we are in a very, very competitive environment where
the the the pilots are very homogeneous level.
Everyone lands in 30 seconds. You see, yeah, yeah, you see,
it's very impressive tactics. Tactics is very important.
And and so you earn your points at the end on the final line
when you're very top pilots. And so it is very important to
have a faster blighter. This situation has been not
answered correctly on this CRV primary in December yet, but it
will, I mean things take time and it will be better.
I think we will find a better solution.
The IT was voted to limit the trimming to 10 millimetre
instead of 20 millimetre where this doesn't change anything on
the on the real problematic as you can understand.
And so it's adding more troubles to the organization and to the
pilots because a lot of checking and more work, basically more,
more work. But still the compromise to make
is still there. You understand, it's even, it's
even more compromise to make because it's like having a
smaller speed range almost. And if if the speed range was
not 14 but 1010 centimetre, it would be even worse.
We would the the winner would be the one making a very, very
unstable wing that would be even more reward for instability I.
Don't understand? I'm sorry.
Yeah. So you will read my document
because it's, yeah, it's, it's well explained.
OK, Anyways, Yeah, it's it's well explained.
And if you don't understand you, you come to me.
Yeah. But yeah, that's the situation
here. What else can be said?
So the ASO 3 which is made for this holes as pitch stability
that is very marginal. So it's like anything
instability when you're on the boot side of things, it's kind
of staying if you go, But if you are very on the edge, you go on
the bad side and then it's it's not good enough.
It's and it's only a small difference makes a difference
between enough stability, not enough stability and then when
you don't have enough stability, you can get collapse on the bar
without so much warning. So you can try to pilot it, but
eventually you get to collapse. Because the profile is
inherently unstable, basically. Yeah, the shape of the profile
and these, these wings, they are structured with some outside
plastic rods like mini. And because this profile is just
borderline stability, the plastic plastic rods can have an
effect on the shape of the profile.
Plastic rods are for line stability the attachment points.
Then. I know these lines, but what are
they stable for? Well, what are they making
stable like? What do they help with?
These lines when they are big tension or loose tension, they
affect the shape of the of the profile.
Right. So so their what is their
purpose? To be inside the kind of?
Like why do we? Yeah, we have it for good
performance and good rigidity of the profile.
OK so basically to for profile shape that is why we put lines.
Too Yeah, yeah, yeah This is this is to keep to keep the
shape of the profile because it's a 2 liner there's not so
many lines if we don't have plastic.
This is this shit is not flying. OK, OK, OK.
Like it won't hold well. No, it won't fly.
Basically this is we can't make a paraglider like this without
this plastics. OK, OK.
So basically the length of the plastic in in the in the in the
profile is deciding the behaviour of the wing.
The shape of the profile yeah, exactly.
And, and, and so because this profile is just at the limit of
stability if you push the plastic, you put some staple to
make it very tight, tight, tight then you will get more speed
like I just explained on the start, but less solidity, right,
right, right. So it can.
Just go. And then when it then it's it's
not nice because you can get collapse without warning.
Makes sense. OK.
And so at the moment on the Enzo 3, we are having sometime issue
with some gliders because they, they tend to shrink then you
know, the close is 9 plus and they, they shrink quite fast.
Can can shrink fast and depending on condition humidity,
we not controlling still very well this process and some in
those three ends up being quite unstable.
And the the the pilots have issues with collapses.
So specially tip collapses. The more you fly your wing, the
more the fabric shrinks. That's why the lines, the
plastic rods get tighter. Yeah, because they get tighter.
Profile becomes more unstable. Yeah.
And that is why collapses can come without warning.
Yeah. And this is, it's important to
understand that it is specific to Enzo 3 and other CCC gliders
because they are built really for racing on the edge of
stability. So we're talking about 5
millimetre difference on a plastic rod that is more than 2m
or not 2m long. Wow.
Yeah, it's. Insane, man.
Yeah, it's so sensitive. Yeah, yeah, right.
It is. It is insane and on the more
general public products they don't, we don't have this
problem of working with a given speed travel, you know EN
paragliders we can put 20 centimetre whatever is necessary
for a given profile and and so the profile are much more
stable. They have big margin and then
the plastics movement doesn't really make an effect because we
are, we are not on the edge of the stability.
So we are far stable and the change of plastic doesn't make
any difference. It's not, it's not significant.
Yeah, it's too, too. Yeah, minimal too, too.
Small. Yeah, Yeah.
What is the fuss about? Why are people angry?
What what are they saying? That they have to trim the rods
or this engine is not as it was like?
What is? What is that whole discussion
all about? Yeah, some people, they're not
happy because they are not fast enough.
They're not they're. Not winning, no, but I mean the
the glider is not fast enough compared to others.
So they're not collapsing, but they're not fast enough.
Some others, they're they're complaining because they are
collapsing. They're fast, but they're
collapsing. And for sure, it's difficult to,
like I said, it's, it's, we are pushing a compromise between
collapse and, and velocity And the other things is that they
are the, the production have some variation of course, in
some cases because we're talking few millimetres, 2 wings build
at the same time and goes to different people.
Eventually they end up different instability.
And so it makes people not happy because their previous industry
was not the same as the as one here.
But we're dealing with our customers like like usual.
I mean, it's been, this wing is on the market since 2017.
And so it's always been this problem.
Can I ask you about the certification?
Thing that no. Why do some people say that they
are not the same as certified Like what is their argument in
that? I don't know.
I'm not sure someone say that because nobody can know how it
was certified for, for us it, it is like certified since 2017.
We changed the plastic in 2021 because before 2021 we were
having plastic which shrink faster than the clothes was
shrinking, right. So after one season the people
were complaining because they were not fast enough.
So the people with my new wing, they were just killing them on
the final guide. And so they were the solution
was to re tight the plastic with temples to make them tighter
again. And then they eventually it was
making it too tight and they were collapsing.
But it was nice gliders, very stable when it was shrinked like
that, very stable gliders. Fun to fly.
Fun to fly for cross country it's perfect, but then for high
level competition it was not competitive enough because of
this consistent but so this CCC certification is is a compromise
that has been found between manufacturers and CRVL in 2013
fourteen something like that to try to have something that is
not open class, but that is not EN to not put pressure on the EN
certification. That was a problem in the past
where we had the competition wing ENDS and it was creating
problems on the the END certification mean confidence
that the pilot have and it was a better situation to create a
specific sports class which is CCC.
Sorry, competition class now yeah, not open but it's a
compromise where it's there's still some tests to do.
We cannot do any manufacturer cannot do stupid wings.
There are some tests, so it's not open class like it was
before 2011, but it is much more open than Ian.
So you can certify the small wing and all the other size.
You can sell certified by the manufacturer, but you need to
store the sample, make videos and it's simple, more simple
test to perform for the certification.
But for me, the biggest issue we have is not about so
certification, because the certification doesn't really
help us in a way because it's, it's not intuitive, but to
create a collapse because we you got collapse when you go for
speed in the turbulence. But when we do certification, we
create a collapse, create a collapse.
It's a better behaviour when the the the profile is more fragile,
yeah. So when it's more stable, it's.
Easier to. It's easier, the results are
better, but in the reality it's not the case anyway.
So I mean, this certification is not where we can help the system
to to help the safety at the moment is the the the the
solution. In my opinion there are several
solutions proposed and we need to all agree to something that
will work. I have a very pragmatic approach
is we need to kill this incentive on final glide.
So there is no advantage anymore to go faster than his fellow
pilot. So for that there is either
conical and expectation. So instead of being a cylinder,
it's a cone shape and of protection or it's altitude
bonus on the cylinder. But it could be made equivalent
anyway. And the effect of that would be
that there is an optimum speed because you know the glider has
a polar. When you go faster you will
arrive nowhere always. OK, so, so there is a compromise
then and we can set the parameter.
So the compromise is high speed or speed or speed or even full
speed. But because it's very flat, the
result, you don't make any difference.
You can go faster, but you will not earn more points, you
understand. So when you do that, you will
help a lot on the safety of the whole thing.
You will help for the safety of the models which are designed
differently for this ecosystem because now there is no more
incentive to go crazy unstable in in year 4 in the profile we
close year 4. And why is it not being adapted?
Like what's what's stopping this bureaucracy?
Yeah, it's it's also people need to make their mind and agreed on
on things. I mean I.
It's hard to convince a bunch. Yeah, because another solution
which is brought by some Moses, is to limit the speed.
Like have instruments which would measure airspeed and we
would limit the speed live, you understand?
Yeah. So you'll have on your cockpit,
you'll have your speed. And like on the road, you don't
pass a certain speed. OK.
Wow, that's kind of. Cool.
Yeah. That's fun.
So you're going to have speed limits in the air, so.
Speed limit on the air. So that's the other solution.
But this one for me is not very pragmatic because we don't have
the tool to do it right now. Yeah.
Probably you'll have to put it in the hardness.
Somewhere you you also need a lot of backup because you know
how it is. We have instruments.
Sometimes they war, sometimes they don't war.
They need to be reliable. They need to be comparable.
All of this is is quite complicated for a small sport,
like we are very small sport with little means.
And so I think we need to be pragmatic and change a little
bit our scoring system and our rules of CCC to make something
that will encourage or not even encourage.
We'll make the best wing, a stable wing.
I think I can close the wig.